so you feel the older lenses are are
somehow
lend to a better story and forgive me i
i don't know it's like more character
so the lens the lens itself uh the older
lenses tend to have more character
which can be described in like you know
maybe the the edges blur a little bit
differently
or um certainly lens flares are very
different
uh especially with anamorphic um and
there's some wonderful new anamorphic
lenses i've actually filmed with them as
well and they looked beautiful
but i just happen to really love the
characteristics the way it bends light
is slightly differently
slightly different or again the way it
pulls focus maybe to the center because
the edges
or maybe the the the sharpness starts to
dissipate towards the edges
which could it in one respect could be a
little bit maybe scary for a filmmaker
going oh i want to make sure the shot's
in focus
but if you understand that and know that
going in you know where
the lens might be softer and so you're
not going to frame it that way to where
it would be
an issue or you make sure you're paying
attention like oh the top of their heads
may be getting a little too blurry so
you reframe a little bit to make sure
they're
in the sweet spot of the lens a lot of
the older lenses have sweet spots so
you got to kind of understand and know
that or else you could get yourself in
trouble where
the people are out of focus but
but i just love the characteristics of
it and when you look at
certainly the filmmakers that influenced
me the most they almost
always have shot on anamorphic and some
of those that very same
models that i've used from the cowas and
the hawks and uh
and even some of the ingenues um
you know some spielbergs and the and the
you know uh uh
kubricks and all that use those same
same kind of
uh lenses so um
that was always kind of a dream of mine
was to to be able to shoot on those
someday and then
it's come to fruition on a couple
projects i've gotten to to use some of
those vintage
uh uh lenses which was
exciting for me because i'm kind of a
camera nerd that way i really
geek out on all the different technology
and i love new technology but i also
love the old stuff too
so again that's where it comes back to
me loving to
figure out a way to marry the two
together
and that's just always a a kind of
exciting challenge to me and if you buy
those lenses on ebay do you then later
sell them
again um
you know i have some old russian uh
lenses
that just do some really cool uh bouquet
or boca
the way it uh kind of almost a circular
blur to them uh those are really cool
i've used those
actually i used one of those on
california christmas for a scene
to me they're always like they're tools
that you can use for a certain situation
it might be really
perfect for that moment and
so i've got those i've got i just i
actually just adapted a
a 70s ingenue zoom lens for tele it was
a television lens
and uh it's a gorgeous lens and i got it
for like 150 bucks on ebay
and that lens probably when it came out
was fifty sixty thousand dollars
but uh
you couldn't really use it on a modern
camera especially the the mounting
wouldn't work
um and so what i discovered i had to
modify the mount
on it in order to get it to work with
another adapter
that would then work on the i have a
blackmagic uh
pocket camera so to get it to even fit
on there i had to modify
the the rear mounting element on it
which i took it off the lens and kind of
did everything i needed to do with it to
make it fit and then
the other thing about those lenses and
probably why you could get them
i think other people are discovering
this now because i've seen the price of
them go up
giving away your secrets they're now
like 600
ish in that range that i've been seeing
but the lens itself
is a eight millimeter to 112 millimeter
zoom which is a pretty decent zoom
but it's the size
of of the uh
the back glass is too small for a modern
camera
uh like a like a black magic um what
happens when you put that lens on there
you have a
crazy vignette so you basically see the
circle of the back element
so that you're only seeing and
everything else is black you know and
you've got this little circle
and that's the reason why most people
wouldn't buy that lens
and you can get them for the price that
you can get them but
on certain versions of those lenses they
had built-in doublers
so basically there's a magnifier on the
back end of the lens that you can flip
and what the purpose of it originally
was for those lenses is it made them
twice the focal length so you could then
you know on the just a flip of a switch
you could double your focal length you
could go from a 100 to a 200 millimeter
zoom and you know there's all sorts of
cool things you could do with that
well what i discovered is that you could
take that same lens
and put the doubler on it
and now it fills the full frame of my
camera
so i don't have an 8 to 112 millimeter i
actually have
a 14 to 220 millimeter lens
which is still a great focal length for
me to have on my camera i mean that's as
wide as i'll ever need it and that's
almost as tight as i'll ever need it and
so that was the experiment of wanting to
make that lens work and figure out how
to adapt it to get it to work on my
camera
and it worked it's it's really pretty
incredible
and in fact the blackmagic is there's a
crop factor
like a on that so effectively what my
camera is is
i think it's a 22 millimeter to 400 and
like
450 millimeter zoom and it looks
beautiful i did a bunch of test footage
with it and
again it has those old characteristics
that i love
looks like you know you're shooting
something in the 60s or 70s
um and you know cost me 150 bucks
so there you go um and i will use it on
a project
uh i guarantee somewhere somehow i'll
end up using that lens
um for something so you keep them safely
stored away
yeah yeah and i bring it with me on my
project so um
yeah so it was so interesting about that
ongenew is that it's a it's a
french-made lens
and the style of a mount that it had
was i think it was called the b3 like a
bayonet iii
and japanese lenses made it
you know american all that stuff they
all had this b3 mount
well i was able to find online
b3 adapters to micro four thirds
so i went great here we go i can i can
just
buy this adapter and it'll work no it
didn't work
there was a piece on that back element
that on that back mount element on the
ingenu
that was several millimeters deeper than
it was on
like the canons of the same era or the
other ones that that adapter would work
on
did not work on mine so i looked i had
to really like
break it down like what is stopping this
adapter from mounting correctly
i figured out which pieces it was and
i'm like okay
so how do i get this
this piece luckily it was aluminum so it
was fairly soft that mounting piece
so i was able to take metal files like i
said get it down
to the right level which actually took a
long time longer than i was expecting
and then i went with you know some finer
uh sanding materials and
and got it to be smooth and then i like
you know
finished it so that it was wouldn't
affect the adapter at all
and then it worked mounted on there and
and
i didn't know if that would change your
rear focus element
i was a little bit worried that maybe
that would affect it
to where this adapter is made for a
certain thing
and your back glass needs to be a
certain distance from your sensor in
order for it to work
so i wasn't sure by filing this piece
down
if i would was a risk i was like i could
be possibly
ruining this at this mount for my lens
and it might not it might not work
because it'll just be a few millimeters
different
but luckily it actually worked right out
of the gate as soon as i mounted it i
was able to focus all the way through
and those old
the other cool thing about those old
lenses is they have a back element
adjuster so it's basically like a screw
a nut that you undo and you can then
move
and it moves the distance from that back
glass so you can really dial it in
you can dial them in to to be
i'm trying to remember the term but it's
basically at your widest focal distance
you're in focus and when you zoom in
through the whole thing you're in focus
and only certain lenses can do that and
new lenses don't a lot of them don't do
that or they're like sixty thousand
dollars like i said that lens will do
this
but your two thousand dollar canon can't
do that you know what i mean
so having this lens that has that
ability is pretty darn
cool and i was able to dial that all in
i was i was actually really surprised
that one worked
to be honest but um i then
bought two more of that style lenses to
try and experiment
one i failed one i can't get it to adapt
correctly
but the other one i was it was a cannon
one was a fujinon i couldn't get the
fujinon to work right
but the cannon i was able to to get to
work
um and i just used that one on a
commercial shoot
not that long ago and it worked great
and again that was a similar focal
length so right now that's like a 28 to
480 millimeter zoom if you want to know
those are the old eng lenses
okay so those are old like uh you know
60s 70s 80s
really like 70s is probably where most
of these are from
but they're eng lenses uh so like um
like beretta and shows like that like
yeah yeah yeah
and uh um you can probably find that
most of them are like fujinon and canon
like on ebay and stuff
and they're um the i'm trying to think
of if it's there the two-thirds
inch eng lenses is what i'm talking
about and they need to have that
built-in doubler so it's like a two
times
focal length piece on it and they look
really funky they come off the back of
the lines that's how you can usually
tell they're on there
but in the description always i you know
make sure you get one because if you get
one that doesn't have that doubler
and you try and put it on a modern
camera most of them um
it will again like i said you'll just
have that big
vignette uh where you know it's not
really usable
um but once you have that the doubler
that's built in onto them
that you know you can never use it
really without it on so you just have to
live with this is my new focal length is
is the double
of this lens you know what i mean so
because you said it gets too close to
the sensor
it's not as it gets too close to the
sensor it's just that the back element
is too small to cover the full
width of your sensor so but what happens
is when that with those built-in
doublers is it's a piece of glass
that basically if this is the back of
the lens
if this is your piece of glass this this
magnifier
comes on top of it and it is bigger than
that piece
and that magnifica magnification
uh it creates the image to be big enough
to cover your
your whole lens or your whole i'm sorry
sensor so you don't you no longer have
those
vignette on your on your thing so
um yeah it's pretty cool pretty cool
little little uh
trick i'm not the only one who's
discovered it either there's there's
other people
uh who have who have experimented with
it but definitely
um it's not like a common thing but uh
i always love that stuff like i said
i've taken old uh still camera lenses
i've got some zeiss lenses from the from
the 50s and 60s that i've adapted
from exact amounts
which is a really interesting mount
luckily i was able to find some people
that have made pieces to
to that can adapt that to like cannon
mount
um and uh and then i take the cannon
mount and adapt that to the
micro four thirds or you know whatever
the the different challenges are
or different camera that we might be
putting it on um
but i've gotten some great uh those the
old zeiss's are usually at least a
couple hundred
dollars but to me if you can find a
clean one that doesn't have
uh you know a bunch of scratches on the
lens or
a bunch of fungus on the lens um
uh they're still they're really great
pieces of glass
i have a 25 millimeter zeiss um
carl zeiss lens from the 50s that's
incredible
it's tack sharp still today and it's
just a really really
nice piece of glass that i got for a
couple hundred dollars
where anything modern would cost you
several thousand at least for that
same focal length and and quality
how do you protect it from fungus do you
keep it away from moisture
yeah the you know the funny thing about
fungus is that it actually
uh it's hard to to
you know say why some lenses get it and
some don't but it is probably
has to do with moisture and and how
sealed they are
um most of the time though fungus really
won't affect your image too much it
affects how light comes in
to the lens and will like bend uh
like like uh kind of the flares so
sometimes
even a little fungus is kind of cool on
an old lens in my opinion
now if it's right in the dead center of
your lens maybe that then becomes
annoying
but if it's just around the edges again
it could give you some of those
qualities that i actually even like
so i won't necessarily turn down a lens
on ebay if it's got a little fungus on
it just depends on where it is
but things like scratches and things
that really will kind of affect
the image then obviously you've got to
stay away from that but
yeah i mean it depends on what project
you're doing if you need something super
clean and you want it to look
you know tack sharp like that then those
lenses won't be for you but
if you're trying to do something that
has a little bit more of that style to
it then
i say go for it experiment with it and
and see what you can do
because uh you know to me that's that's
what
will set your project apart make it make
it feel a little different you know
how would you know if a lens has fungus
on it if you're seeing it on
some site that's selling well i always
ask those questions and most people
uh that i've discovered they will
they'll list what's wrong with the lens
and stuff like that so most of them will
say
no you know clean glass no scratches
fungus free they'll say something like
that
or they'll talk about the blades the
blades aren't oily because a lot of
times the lenses
if the like they'll have like a a leak
in the the it'll affect how the
uh shutter and the aperture works
not the shutter but the the aperture
itself so they'll list like what's
you know you know you just have to read
the details then ask questions if you
you know and i'll ask that a lot of
times i'll ask you know
you know is it doesn't have this or does
it have that to clarify
and again like i said sometimes i might
be okay with it they go is there fungus
is it like all over the the lens or is
it like just on the edges you know
and uh and i might still buy it if it
has it if it
if that's what i'm going for you know in
that moment and if the price is right
you know
you